Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And we're excited to be here, Ruffians!
Well, just like...
Every FUWAMOCO Morning, today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today on only our 55th episode!
That's so weird.
Thank you, Ruffians!
It's weird, but thank you!
It's been 55 episodes, but maybe, you know, there's still some Ruffians
If you aren't quite sure what FUWAMOCO Morning is, it can be confusing.
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts using the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Are you ready to start your new week today?
Huh?
Moco-chan, I think we are too, right?
Hopefully.
Hopefully!
Why?
Well, I think there was a Ruffian that had a Pero Sighting.
Well, where was Pero this time?
Let's see.
De-den!
Oh.
Are you feeling alright?
Maybe your head is hurting a bit.
You wear glasses.
Is the prescription okay?
Yeah, well, maybe you should go lay down or something.
You know, that's a lot of pero you're seeing there.
That's not right, okay?
There's only one Pero, and even at that, there's sometimes too many, okay?
And you know Pero is Pero.
He's not the sun, the sky, or the grass.
But thank goodness for that, right?
The sun is the sun, the grass is the grass, the sky is the sky.
Not Peron.
Yeah.
But, you know, we know things might have been tough recently.
You know, it's the end of the year and everything.
Yeah.
It's rough, right?
It's rough.
There might be a lot of stress and pressure on you two, but maybe it's time to have a little rest and then try again in a bit.
Yeah, rest is good.
Take it easy, okay?
Got it.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
But!
Hopefully everything's a little bit better.
It'll be okay.
It's good, it's colorful.
A colorful world.
Colorful is good, I guess.
But more happily!
More excitingly!
Ruffians.
On Friday, we had a big collab with Advent.
We played Play-Doh, right?
Play-Doh!
But then, we shared our biggest announcement of the year so far!
On January 1st, Advent will be revealing our New Year outfit!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Exciting!
A new outfit for FUWAMOCO!
Our first new outfit!
How excited are you, Ruffians?
Excited!
I don't know if you can be more excited than we are, but... Extremely excited!
Achoo!
I don't know, the Ruffians.
What do you think they'll look like just looking at the silhouettes?
You know, maybe you see some paw-like shapes, maybe.
Maybe Fuwawa has a ponytail, maybe.
I'm sure that's what that is.
And me, I'm looking not just fuzzy, but a little curly, too.
Curly, yeah.
Do you think that's maybe a fun ring in our hair, too?
Could be, but maybe not.
What else?
What else could it be, Ruffians?
It is!
OMG, it is!
Oh my gosh!
What?
Ruffians, you have to join us to find out, but we want to make sure.
Please don't die, okay?
You have to make sure that your heart will withstand it, okay?
Please let us know what you think the look like though, okay?
Use the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCNEWYEAR!
We hope that you'll be there for us on January 1st at 6.30pm PT or 11.30am JST.
BAU BAU!
And just to let you know,
All the other Advent girls' outfits.
They're killer too.
Don't miss it, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, speaking of outfits, Moco-chan.
Not just New Year outfits.
Ruffians!
Did you see the photo that Icomochi-mama took of me?
It's embarrassing, but it seems like you really liked it, so I posted it to Twitter!
Did you see it?
Hi!
You know, a lot of people seem to think that Fuwawa posted it, or something, like she made me do it, but... I didn't do anything like that one time.
Okay, don't think that everything on Twitter is done all by Fuwawa, because it's not!
You know, I don't even know why you think that, but... The silly things are always Moco-chan.
What?
Hi.
I did the best pose I could.
Okay.
What do you think?
Do I make a good pose?
Cute!
Subarashii!
Kawaii!
Tasukaru!
Praise!
Praise me, Ruffians!
It's cute!
Kawaii?
Kawaii!
ASMR Icomochi-mama so talented!
We want to know more about what you like, Ruffians.
If you haven't checked out Icomochi-mama's Twitter yet, please do, okay?
We have the best mama in the whole wide world!
Icomochi-mama!
And you know, even Fuana-senpai likes to retweet at me, too.
What do you think that means, Moco-chan?
I like Bona-senpai too.
Maybe that means she likes the Mocopony too.
BAU BAU!
Bona has good taste too.
I like Bona-senpai.
But I like Oda-senpai of course.
As you might know, yesterday was a very important homework day for FUWAMOCO.
Do you know why we're Ruffians?
We want to say thank you!
Thank you, Ruffians.
We couldn't have done it without you.
But, well, you know, Moco-chan gets really scared of updates and changes, so naturally, we avoided them at all costs.
You know, and we were having some issues that prevented us from doing because
You know, our situation is a bit different, okay?
There's two of us.
But you know, finally, we made a big jump to a bunch of new software as well as some big hardware updates.
There were a ton of bumps though.
Watch screen monitor?
No.
That would be nice though!
Two PC?
No.
But, you know, for some reason, if we put our computer to sleep now, sometimes it doesn't want to wake up.
You know, I sort of understand that feeling, but every time it happens, we have a bit of a heart attack.
Yeah, but it'll be okay!
Yeah, we'll figure out all the new quirks for sure.
We'll figure it out.
You know, things aren't perfect.
Now some things look kind of fuzzy instead of crisp.
You know, fuzzy is good too!
Sometimes you want things crisp.
You don't want to have a fuzzy apple.
You want to have a crisp apple pie.
We can do some new cool things now!
So... That's good.
It's exciting.
It's good.
We're really excited!
But you know... The next thing is...
Soon.
Ish.
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
We worked hard.
It was scary but I did it.
That face is FUWAMOCO's reflection?
I'd say that's accurate.
But with maybe a bit more... A bit more sweat marks on it.
BAU BAU!
Well, there's been some more happy news recently, Ruffians.
Wow, we have a second scoop!
Thank you, Ruffians, for your FUWAMOCO scoop!
We got a really, really good tip from a Ruffian.
Well, you know, last week was a very special anniversary for all of hololive Indonesia's second generation hololive!
A big congratulations on your 3rd anniversary to Aoi-senpai, Anya-senpai, and Riri-senpai!
To celebrate it, Ai-senpai released a new song called Slop by Step, which actually has dual audio in Japanese and Indonesian.
That's pretty cool.
You know, it's always so amazing to us how many of our Airi-senpai can speak 3 languages.
I'm just a bit jealous.
I'm a bit envious, you know?
They make it seem so easy.
It's not easy.
And dual audio too.
But you know the song is super catchy and really inspiring too.
With a full 3D MV.
So you definitely need to check it out if you haven't.
You need to check it out, okay?
You know, I still can't believe they're already celebrating their third anniversary.
Time passes so fast.
What?
I think the Ruffians know that.
BAU time.
Ruffians, before we know it, it's gonna be our half anniversary soon, too.
Really, really.
Oh my gosh.
But- But dog doesn't count, okay?
What?
Dog doesn't count.
Dog doesn't- Because humans can't understand dog, okay?
One, two, three.
BAU.
What?
Thank you so much for all our hololive ID senpais for being so wonderful to us and Advent!
BAU BAU!
Selamat Hari Anniversary!
Think Moco-chan, in only about 3 years it'll be our 3rd anniversary too.
In less than 3 years.
Two years and some months.
Almost done.
But...
I guess no more time to be happy.
We think there's maybe something we should talk about.
Yeah, I think Ruffians, you might be misunderstanding something.
Misunderstanding something.
Misunderstanding something!
Hai.
Yeah, I'm concerned, you know.
I think it'll be bad if all the Ruffians continue living their lives with this misunderstanding.
You need to know, okay?
The truth.
Yeah.
You can't have this wrong misperception.
Wrong perception.
Misperception.
Is that how it goes?
Misperception?
It's a misunderstanding!
Ruffians, you know, every week on Mondays, which is yesterday, today, Moco-chan tries to eat natto, right?
I do my best.
Twice.
Don't eat it twice.
I made a misconception.
Okay, misperception.
But, Ruffians, every time we make sure to thank the farmers in Tochigi Prefecture.
We do!
Even if we can't eat it the best.
If you haven't heard of Tochigi before, it's a prefecture in Japan that's not too far from Tokyo.
It's only about two hours by car.
But... But... You know, Tochigi...
It's not famous for its natto.
It's not a natto perfection.
Not at all.
No, we just say thank you to them because they make the natto that we're eating.
It says made in Tochigi.
But if anything, Tochigi is famous for its strawberries.
Strawberry.
It's Japan's Ichigo Okoku.
Strawberry kingdom.
Because you know it's known for its special strawberry variant variety.
The Tochi Otome.
It's very popular in Japan.
Not natto.
But Tochigi is also known for its gyoza and wagyu too.
Mito City in Ibaraki is said to be the birthplace of natto.
So naturally, you know there's a lot of yummy natto made here.
So, you know, maybe you're planning a trip to Japan sometime soon!
You could go and visit Tochigi and have some yummy strawberries, and then you could head over to Mito City in Ibaraki for some delicious natto too!
Or you know, you could just stay in Tochigi for the strawberries!
And the Wagyu.
And the Gyoza.
Make sure to take the farmers to Hukui, okay, Ruffians?
Do it for us.
BAU BAU!
Does this count?
Ruffians, I saw some of you being like, yes, the Tochigi, not the Tochigi, yes.
You're misunderstanding.
That's it for Natto for today.
No!
Because today is Monday, which means a new week and a new challenge!
So today, just like every week, Moco-chan's going to do her best to conquer her fear.
It's not Ico Natto!
I feel like it wasn't a fear, but maybe... Maybe...
It's developing.
Well, Moco-chan, you know we've been here for a while, so please show some good progress today, okay?
I'm really gonna give it my best.
I really, I do every time, but I really am.
I don't know if I'm convinced, but for Ruffians that might not know, natto is a common breakfast food in Japan.
It's made of fermented soybeans.
And it's pretty sticky and slimy and kind of smelly sometimes, but
It's really, really, really good for you.
I eat it every day.
It's a super food!
FUWAMOCO-chan, you need to eat it every day too.
I'm going to eat this.
The smell!
It's not horrible, but it is strong.
So when you feel a bit queasy, it may be a bit strong.
Queasy?
Queasy!
FUWAMOCO-chan, you know what?
Fuffy.
Fuzzy.
Queasy.
I bought something special for you today.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, why?
I thought you know.
What else is strong smelling that you could add to the nuts?
No!
I don't want more strong stuff!
I bought some sesame oil.
It'll be yummy.
Smell it, Moco-chan.
No, no, I don't want it.
The oil is just gonna make it more sticky.
No!
Okay, I'm going to add it!
Ooh!
A lot came out.
Okay.
Oh!
No oil spills.
Okay, now it's time to pop it on.
Durian!
Durian and natto oil.
It smells so good!
Oh, I think... I think Moco-chan will be able to do her best today.
I do like sesame oil.
It smells really good, Moco-chan.
Okay, it's ready.
I think actually that was the perfect amount.
That was the perfect amount of sesame oil.
Yeah.
It smells good, right?
I can't smell it yet.
It smells like sesame oil.
Why are you making... I wear socks!
Okay!
Today is the day!
What does sesame oil smell like?
Sesame oil.
It smells like oil and sesame.
It smells very delicious.
Confidence, Moco-chan?
I don't know.
Maybe it's different.
Last time when we did the soy sauce, it was not good.
But now!
Soy for soy does not equal joy.
What?
No!
But now, I don't know.
Soy for sesame.
Oh.
Okay, she has a lumpy.
It just smells like sesame oil.
Should I chew it?
Yeah!
Should I chew it, Ruffians?
You can do it, Moco-chan!
I feel like if I chew it, I might ruin everything.
Chew it.
Well, you could swallow it, and then you could try again.
Okay, I'm gonna try chewing it then.
Okay!
3, 2, 1!
Oh, it's in there.
It's in there.
Oh, that's a big sting.
Oh?
Her eyebrows aren't... Oh?
Iketa?
Did she... She did it!
I eat it.
Oh, okay, next bean!
It tasted like sesame oil.
Next bean!
Can you do two this time?
Can I do two?
Do two, Moco-chan!
Is sesame oil a miracle?
Get two this time, Moco-chan.
No, I need to eat three.
I don't taste it in my mouth at all.
This shouldn't count!
What do you mean?!
What do you mean about that?!
I ate it!
One second, I'm gonna try again.
Another bean.
Here we go!
It's in!
Okay, okay.
Oh no.
The eyebrows.
It's okay, you're good.
You chewed it.
I cleared it.
Okay, time for another, Moco-chan!
Time for another!
You can do three, that'll be your high score.
Will you be happy if I get the high score?
This one looks really sticky though.
You can do it, Moco-chan!
You can do it!
Moco-chan!
Hang in there!
I did it!
It went all over my lips and I really did not like that!
I really did not like it all over my lips and now I have it on my fingers.
You did it, Moco-chan!
I did it!
Ruffians, you're proud of me!
The sesame oil was the cheat code.
Okay, Moco-chan, but how are we gonna proceed from here?
I don't know.
I think you have to do a mouthful, no?
NO!
I did three.
I did three beans, okay?
Can you do two more?
Last time!
Two at once, Moco-chan?
No!
Last time!
Two at once?
I think you could do it.
Last week, I just touched it with my tongue and it was not good.
Okay.
See, maybe this is just a case of you have to take one step forward and then five steps back.
Right?
Moco-chan!
BAU BAU!
I did my best!
Are you proud, Ruffians?
I'm hungry beans!
Are you proud?
You did it, Moco-chan!
Next step is to eat the whole package.
No.
You can do it.
It might just take a lot of sesame oil, but... BAU BAU!
Remember, Ruffians, how hard Moco-chan has been working these past many, many countless weeks to challenge the natto and apply that to anything you want to do, okay?
You can do it!
BAU BAU!
Why are you laughing?
Because you're silly, huh?
It's true!
Well, let's continue on to our Doggie of the Day!
Our Doggie of the Day is... Da-da!
Jake!
FUWAMOCO!
Jake really loves to walk, huh?
This day, I think you know he was being a bit stubborn and cold outside, you know?
But actually, Moco-chan gets like this sometimes, too.
Sometimes, maybe.
But Jake also really likes snoozing and sniffing things, too.
Using the sniffer, but he's apparently also scared of water bottles.
That makes sense.
Sometimes, you know, they can open really fast, like BAM!
Right.
Yeah, I don't know, but I feel like he's the type to be scared of water bottles in the best way possible.
I know.
They can be scary.
It's okay.
Yeah, well, how does Jake BAU BAU, Moco-chan?
Like a... BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Boy!
Surprise.
But you know, perfect is born.
And I think Jake does a really good job to help us remember that.
It's good, you know, water bottles can be scary.
And that's fine, right?
You know, Jake feels comfortable with you, you know, to be able to show that side of himself.
You know, and he's not afraid to complain about the cold weather either.
Oh, that's nice.
Right?
That just shows how much he loves you.
How comfortable he feels with you.
Right?
You know, and I'm sure that when he can, he'll surely love to snuggle up next to you.
Snuggle!
BAU BAU!
And for today, I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm FUWAMOCO!
Right.
Ah, I'm Abyss.
I feel like I would like to fly.
Take me there!
Fly!
In the sky there.
I'd probably cry.
It should be kind of dangerous because it's cold out.
It might freeze.
Your tears might freeze.
Bye.
Make sure you stay warm, stay safe, okay?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day, we have... When did Fuwawa start drinking matcha lattes?
It sounds like you have a machine for it, so do you drink it often?
And because of your unique way of drinking tea, is there anything special you do to your lattes?
First, Ruffians, do you think I have a machine?
To add to it first, I did start drinking matcha lattes a few years ago.
At first, I always thought it was really hard to make them on your own, like it was impossible.
But that's not it at all.
You just have to make sure you have the proper
Uh-uh.
You know, just a chashaku to scoop the matcha out of the container.
A chasen to whisk the tea.
And then an ochawan to mix it in with the tea cup.
And then my hands!
Power!
I have it almost every day.
It's like my special treat to myself.
But only whenever I feel like I need it.
Almost every day.
Ruffians!
Yeah.
Sometimes she has it twice a day.
That's only when I really need it.
But Moco-chan, the last time I made it, I made one for you.
You did.
You did make one for me.
I did.
Can you do T-70?
I studied Urasenke.
But Urasenke method for a little bit, but I don't really remember it too much.
I'd like to learn more though.
But yeah.
There's really nothing special that I do to it, but I usually like having it cold, like a cold latte.
With soy milk.
Soy milk.
It has to be soy milk for me, otherwise it's just, it's not quite right.
Yeah, but Ruffians- Different milks have different tastes, you know?
I know, yeah.
But you should definitely try it, it's not that difficult.
And then also if you're getting all the lumps in it, then you can use, what's it called?
The shifter.
The shifter, yeah.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions, your scoops, your questions, your Doggie of the Day, your peros and our sightings!
Thank you.
Remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is only a show that we make together, so we hope that it will continue to be just like that, okay?
Thank you so much, FUWAMOCO!
For our next stream, we have De-den!
White Album!
It's this season!
It's the snowy season!
Snowy season!
And that means that today, we're starting the classic winter vision novel, White Album.
And it's a game that's very special to us, and I was actually playing the original version last year, but even though I was using a lot of different walkthroughs and was very, very careful to save a lot, I made a mistake and I kinda got stuck because it was RNG, it wasn't my part, but...
This time, we'll make sure to conquer yuki with no problem.
You know it's a very dramatic and kind of sometimes not the happiest turn of events kind of story but if you're interested in romance and idols back in the 80s in Japan, you'll have to
BAU BAU!
It's really, really, really fun and I'm very excited to play the remake.
I only played the little remake.
The PS3 version.
The PC version, the PS3 version.
With full voice acting and new art too!
New art, but older art, but new art.
And art schedule!
Well, we're gonna be participating in the Yuru Holo Mario Kart tomorrow early in the morning at 3am PT, pretty much today.
But we'll be playing against a bunch of our JP-senpai and Irene-senpai for the very first time in Mario Kart.
And also, there might be some interesting news shared too.
Please check it out!
It was just the best of luck in my life!
I'm glad I made it!
Glad I made it.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today, for spending your Monday morning together with us.
Did you get to hear something good?
Oh.
A miracle happened.
Thank you!
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Ayu!
BAU BAU!
Aya!
Nocsa!
BAU BAU!
Tenryuu.
Backslash.
BAU BAU!
Swarmish.
Black Lotus.
BAU BAU!
Gosher.
Office Mouse.
BAU BAU!
Neko no Matatabi.
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!